China has now surpassed the United  States in life expectancy and a huge  part of this is related to covid but  it's not exactly what you might think  it's not just deaths from covid that  have hurt American life expectancy  although they have it's also that covid  has delayed diagnosis for a number of  different conditions many of which are  much better everyone is much better off  if they are diagnosed early it has also  caused people to forego screenings of  different kinds and in the meantime  China has seen its life expectancy  continue to go up because China is at a  different stage in terms of its Economic  Development where that metric is  increasing more rapidly the U.S has been  passed by China in life expectancy